[Musica]
di tutti
io voglio condividere con voi
un'esperienza che ho fatto ieri
ieri sono stato in olanda uno pensa
all'olanda del paese più come dirà
affollato d'europa la massima tecnologia
l'agricoltura più industrializzata più
inquinata del mondo mi hanno portato in
un posto un vecchio monastero un'oasi
bellissima ma la cosa che più mi ha
impressionato provato con un ricognitore
sono entrato ho visto della sabbia
terreno sabbioso la sabbia noi pensiamo
alla sabbia di mare non è come sabbia di
mare mera nera nera nera palco con le
mani entro c'era era piena di humus un
muscarà vivente humus alcuni agricoltori
bio dinamico bravissimo mi dice sa come
hanno fatto questa questo terreno 800
anni di lavoro i monaci 800 anni di
lavoro raccoglievano i resti e diciamo
le erbe i resti del bosco e un
millimetro all'anno da questa terra
morta la sabbia morta hanno fatto 80
centimetri di terra vivente di humus
impressionante un millimetro all'anno
800 anni di lavoro cosa vuol dire questo
perché questo perché l'uomo di fatto per
sua natura deve intervenire nella natura
l'uomo ha bisogno di cibo l'uomo è un
essere come dire che è strano è la
natura in qualche modo deve intervenire
come può intervenire può intervenire
come stiamo facendo adesso come a cui
nel modo a cui ci ha portato non solo la
cultura industriale ma ci ha portato la
mentalità tecnologica che ha avuto i
suoi benefici che ha avuto i suoi
effetti
voi sapete che c'è quel punto quel punto
la terra è un essere vivente
la terra come tutti gli esseri viventi
si rigenera una forza auto rigeneratrice
noi consumiamo il risorse della terra
quest anno scorso abbiamo finito di
consumare le risorse l'otto agosto ogni
anno questo punto si come dire si sposta
andrà a luglio andrà a giugno andrà a
maggio cosa vuol dire che tutto quello
che avviene dopo questo punto è rubare
risorsa della rai
non le rigenera più è sottrarre energie
alla terra qui da una parte noi possiamo
adottare questo metodo possiamo come
dire sottrarre energie nella lo possiamo
costruire nuove energie costruire una
nuova natura costruire una questo è il
compito ovvero dell'agricoltura prenderà
la natura amandola comprendere le leggi
della natura e ricostruire nuova natura
un terreno ricco di humus un terreno
fertile è una meraviglia e molto
come dire più elevato di un terreno
morto la sabbia questa sabbia ha resa
unica resa vivente resa fertilissima è
una cosa meravigliosa una pianta edibile
una pianta che noi mangiamo che le
piante mica sono liberate da mangiare a
noi
le piante sono lì per autoriprodursi una
pianta edibile il frumento i cereali ma
tutte le piante che l'uomo nel tempo ha
selezionato solo come dire un passo
avanti della natura verso verso un passo
avanti nella natura
l'animale domestico quindi compito e
cultura è portare la natura a un livello
superiore
l'uomo è l'ultimo esser della natura del
più evoluto ma il primo essere di una
nuova natura
questo è il compito dell'uomo quindi
cosa vuol dire vuol dire che il compito
dell'agricoltura non è solo produrre
cibo certo è produrre cibo ea produrre
cibo sano poco ma buono poco ma buono in
occidente troppo ma cattivo poco ma
buono ma è anche come dire costruire
ricostruire un nuovo paesaggio il
paesaggio europeo è frutto del lavoro
soprattutto ai dei monaci dei monaci
benedettini circa stessi che in tutta
europa hanno creato questo paesaggio il
paesaggio che noi abbiamo non è un
paesaggio naturale è un paesaggio
costruito con grande intelligenza con
grande conoscenza e noi se vediamo se
guardiamo io non conosco tanto queste
zone rosse tu vai un posto vedi dove c'è
un monastero vedi i segni le acque come
sono come dire come dire sì strutturate
insomma i boschi del siepi meraviglioso
quindi noi dobbiamo ricostruire questo è
più un altro esempio una volta anni fa
era uno giovane studente di agraria
insomma vado in svezia un'azienda
bellissima e morto meraviglioso
amico e tanti fiori troppi fiori ma
scusa voi non coltivate come perché
perdete tanto terreno per per per per i
fiori e questo architetto mi guarda
seriamente e amorevolmente dice noi
dobbiamo nutrire anche l'anima non solo
il corpo
questo quindi ha il compito di una nuova
agricoltura nutrire il corpo e nutrire
l'anima
c'è un terzo compito noi non viviamo
solo di cibo non viviamo solo di un bel
paesaggio viviamo anche dei rapporti con
gli altri esseri umani
noi viviamo di un organismo sociale e
sull'orgasmo naturale è frutto un'ora
può pensare come vuole dell'evoluzione
del big bang di un creatore sorpreso
naturale frutto di qualcuno che non
siamo noi
l'organismo sociale è il frutto di noi
l'uomo lo può costruire la relazione con
altri uomini
e qual è il punto di partenza
qual è lo starting point oggi per la
coscienza di oggi è l'economia
nell'economia
noi siamo tutti collegati io posso
andare in giappone in cina in qualsiasi
posto parla di economia mi capisco con
tutti
se parlo degli angeli arcangeli serafini
aic rubini non ci capiamo più facciamo
io non ci capiamo più quindi
nell'economia è un linguaggio universale
un linguaggio comune e l'economia è
qualcosa che lega tutti tutti tutti
tutti tutti noi viviamo dell'economia di
altri gli altri vivono di quel po di
economia che facciamo noi quindi bisogna
partire o le con l economia noi siamo
degli apprendisti stregoni
l'economia è una scienza molto giovane
noi serviamo di grandi economisti in
realtà facciamo un po di di pasticci la
filosofia la teologia la scienza dello
spirito cose di grande saggezza antica
l'economia nasce nel nel quattrocento
nella l'economia moderna nasce nel 42
nel rinascimento difatti siamo un po
imbranati difatti risultato lo vediamo
le cose un po mica tanto buone qui
dobbiamo pensare una nuova economia e
qual è la nuova economia è capire cos'è
l'economia dobbiamo pensare non pensare
e di economia di lotta
pensiero darwinista dove l'uomo è in
competizione con l'altro dove c'è
concorrenza dove c'è lotta per
l'esistenza in economia invece che noi
chiamiamo fraterna perché poiché tutti
produciamo per un altro l'uno ha bisogno
dell'altro produttori e consumatori non
solo un conflitto non sono in conflitto
sono accomunati da un compito il
consumatore ha bisogno del produttore
il produttore ha bisogno del consumatore
il produttore è chiamato a produrre un
cibo
perfetto il più perfetto possibile per
il consumatore il corso è praga e via
che è avviato a prendere coscienza ea
pagare il giusto prezzo per questa il
giusto prezzo per questo è il
commerciante che non è una figura
malvagia come il cuore non hanno figura
malvagi al commerciante colui che cerca
di armonizzare in maniera cosciente e
consapevole e altruista questi due poli
quindi dall'economia
noi possiamo partire per creare nuove
comunità oggi le aziende cosa sono le
aziende le aziende le aziende che
funziona sono comunità comunità sono
comunità perché nell'azienda oggi l'uomo
vive l'esperienza della comunità più che
in famiglia più che nelle vecchie
comunità di paese cui la parrocchia
alfagene es el economia economia
nell'azienda oggi viviamo l'essenza
della comunità ma non so la comunità
chiuse sulla comunità aperte a parte che
al calco leggano tutti i fornitori
consumatori che compone da che vivono di
tutti perchè il petrolio non so la
benzina energia elettrica i mattoni li
prendiamo dal lavoro di altri quindi da
lì si può partire una nuova economia che
noi chiamiamo economia fraterna o
economia associativa
questa è una legge tecnica dell'economia
non morale non dobbiamo essere buoni
perché ci vogliamo bene
dobbiamo essere come dire fratelli
perché insieme noi costruiamo costruiamo
un nuovo modello economico e la terra e
il cibo possono essere i punti di
consapevolezza perché tutti abbiamo
bisogno di cibo
tutti siamo figli della terra e lì non
possiamo prescindere e seconda qui per
questo l'agricoltura può essere il punto
di partenza per nuovi rapporti
associativi tra produttori consumatori e
commercianti qualità del prodotto giusto
prezzo
questi sono i concetti i concetti
fondamentali
e da qui passare anche altri settori
economici ma tutti vivono che la stessa
cosa noi oggi produciamo troppo per
buttar via troppo può produrre quello
che serve produrre il prodotto di
qualità dare il giusto valore
quindi dare il giusto prezzo da qui si
passa si deve passare a un organismo
sociale che non è solo economia oggi un
errore dovuto ai tempi è quello di così
a tutto economia tutti parlano di
economia
i politici parlano di economia i
politici in realtà dovrebbero parlare di
giustizia di diritto di senso sociale
anche le autorità religiose parlano di
economia però si parte da lì per creare
un organismo completo che non è solo
economico che è anche di diritto quindi
giuridico che anche culturale artistico
spirituale libertà nella sfera
spirituale libertà nello spirito la
libertà di cultura libertà di ricerca
libertà di arte uguaglianza nella sfera
giuridica uomini di fronte a uomini
uomini di fronte comunico uguali uguali
diritti e uguali doveri fratelli nella
storia economica perché io lavoro per te
e tu lavori per me questo è il compito
che noi ci siamo dati 30 anni fa con
l'agricoltura biodinamica e biologica
tante persone lavorano a 30 anni su
questo progetto iosonopresente di natura
sì e noi vogliamo lavorare per questo e
questo è l'ideale e senza ideali non si
vive
e cos'è la bellezza la bellezza è solo
vie blood messo lovers l'idea che si
congiunge con la materia
l'idea lo spirito e materia creano
bellezza la materia da sola non va bene
lo spirito da solo non va bene l'uno va
nell'alto dei cieli lato sprofonda nella
terra idea spirito e materia insieme
creano bellezza quindi l'arte è la via
della bellezza e la via la redenzione
dell'umanità
buongiorno
[Musica]